物欲で幸福になろうとするからだからダメ
なんですよねだから一生進歩し続けゃええ
んだとえ彼はまだ修行部でしたね全然合一
してないこが伴ってないんでUF自身は
幸福だったのかって考えると僕は幸福では
なかっただろうなと思っ
[音楽]
て簡単にこれ戸塚校長の方チャンネルなん
で自己紹介だけお願いしてもいいですか
はいあはいひろしと申します本名大川
ひろしといいますがコンプライアンスの
関係でえ大花という文字はとって今ひしと
いう人の名前だけで活動しております父親
が大花龍峰甲府の科学の総社権総裁で去年
66歳で死にました父親から2億
3000万訴えらせたんですがその裁判は
流行が死んでも教団名義でやってるんで今
でも続いて今でも嫌がらせを受けてます
よろしくお願いし
ます校長と幸福の科学の関係というかどう
いう接点があるのかについてお塚校長に
伺ってもいいですか私がおと思ったのは
科学という文字だから幸福の科学というの
はあれだなと思ってね歌い文句というのか
な今かんのはね物欲で幸福になろうとする
からおおだからダメなんですよね自分の
価値あるいは価値を獲得すると幸福になる
でしょうでその価値物の価値か自分の価値
かという風に考えたらいいんですよだから
当然進歩するというのは自分の価値を
高めるということだからだから進歩さえ
すりゃ幸福になるこれが私の幸福のなり方
なんですよこいつは金もかからんし一生
有効でしょだから一生進歩し続けりゃええ
んだとそしたらいい一生が遅れるよという
サボってはだめだけど
ねこの辺の考え方は幸福の科学も物欲では
なくて自分の価値を進歩で高めていくって
いうのは共通する部分だったりするんです
かえと一応競技の上ではそうなってます
けどもその競技を語った本本人がどうだっ
たかっていう話ですよね流本人はやっぱ
物欲まみれだったわけでございますね何
千万とかする腕時計をって白金の超高い家
に地上4回地下に行かれてテニスコート
プールサウナ付きのね家を買って年間自費
1億円かかると言われてますけど合有して
金気ラ金の宝石とかねあの装飾品とか付け
まくってなきちゃんてやってたんで教えで
はおせをしなさいとそういう余計なものは
心を曇らせてしまうからそれは尊い記者
喜んで捨てると書いて宗教法人の方にお
伏せしなさいと言うんだけどあのの本人は
もう宝石とか時計とかつけてひゃーって
やってましたっていう話ですねなので彼は
まだ修行不足でしたね校長がよく
おっしゃる地行合一っていう面からすると
全然合一してないちだけやってあの行いが
伴ってないんでUFはね全然できてない
ですねなって
ないうちの支援者の人人女の人がおるん
ですよで彼女がコロナにかかって入院した
時にメールが来たんですよせっかく2週間
かそこら入院するからその間になんか
トレーニングしたいから何したらいいです
かというメールが来たんやで私がね
ちょうどいいから
少年正しく念ずるという少年やってみ
たらって言った彼女はそれをね食事でやっ
たんですよ病院食を食べてまずいもんの
代表でしょ病院食で食べ終わった後に非常
に満足できることが分かったっていう仏教
の念仏かなああいうものの中に我ただたる
をしぶというのがあるんでしょ是非確かめ
て欲しいんやけどね普通だとグルメの
世の中やからうまいものを食わんと満足し
ないでしょそれがねごくまずいものでも
満足できるこの能力は身につけとくといい
よねこれから日本がダメになったって飯を
食うために満足できたら幸せいっぱいや
んこの少年っていうワードはその航空の核
の競技にもあって正しくねずるって書くん
ですけども仏教のねその発生道の中の1つ
ですよねあとはあのたることを知るって
いうまこれも結構高空のカドの競技であっ
てま過ぎたら欲望を持たないようにし
なさいみたいなていうのがあるんですねで
やっぱりその身のたにあったあの夢を持つ
ことはいいこれを願望を持ってそれに
向かって努力するのはいいけれどもただ
あまりにも実際の自分の状況と夢っていう
のはかけ離れすぎたらそれは無理でしょっ
て話で自分の能力を客観的に適正に判断し
てそこから現実的に行けるだろうなって
とこを目指しなさいっていうのがタことを
知るていうあの競技があるんですよところ
がどっこいですね大ほちゃと言いますがね
たることを知るので全然実践できてなかっ
たわけですねいうので広福実現討を作って
で新ジスの3万人程度しか当時いなかった
のに衆議員でざって受かるわけない
でしょっていうで本人が全員分かったんだ
けどもうこれはミッションだからやら
なければならないのだいやいやお前が総理
大臣になりたいだけやんっていう話でで
結局それあの選挙全員全選挙に交させたん
だけどま大爆散して90億するってことで
やりましたから1番足ることをしができて
なかったのはりほちゃんということでね
愉快な仕でございましたね幸福の科学に
ついて概要をもう1回聞きたいんですけど
どういう宗教が背景でできた宗教なんです
かはい幸の科学の競業は一言で説明すると
とにかく流の言うことをそのまま信じ
なさいと一体疑わずにあの100%純粋に
受け止めなさいとで留保が行ったことに
100%従いなさいと右に行けと言ったら
右に行きなさい左に行けと言ったら左に
行きなさいと言ったら死になさいこれ
が競技まとにかくUFの言う通りすこと
やっとけば幸福になりますていう競技でで
バックグラウンドとしてはま仏教が1番
多いですけども仏教キリスト教イスラム教
ヒズ教日本新党あと授教道教とかいろんな
全ての宗教のあのありとあらゆるいいとこ
取り1番あのいいとこだけを取ってきて
それをまとめてでそれを作ったのが流行で
すっていうま設定で言ってしまえば龍宝が
おしさの毎回っていう設定でキリスト教で
言うとこのイエスキリストがあの天に増し
ます我らの父をって言った天に増します父
が竜行っていう設定であのイスラム教で
言うとムハンマドに刑事を下ろした
アッラーが竜子っていう設定こんな感じ
です
ねオムと往復の科学っていうのはどういう
接点なんですかできた時期がほぼ一緒で竜
と麻翔同い年なんですよねちょうどバって
きた時期もほぼ一緒であの進行宗教ブー
ムってわ1980年代後半ぐらいから
いろんな進行宗教が出てくる中で2つが頭
抜けて上がってきてオームの方はさっき
言った原子仏教みたいなとかをちゃんと
修行の方法とかっていうのでま伸びてきて
で航空の科学の方はとにかく競争が東大
法学部出てるというのでなんか深い意味が
あるんじゃないかっていう錯覚を
引き起こして人が集まってきてっていうの
が2つバってきて朝生テレビとかで討論し
たりとかしましたけどもオムの方が先に
事件を起こししちゃって航空の科学は
目立った事件は起こさなかったけれども
進行宗教は全部ダメだっていうバッシング
にあって1回全部ほぼ見自慢にして宇都宮
に2年間引きこもってもう隠居生活みたい
なことをやってだからオムと航空の科学は
ほぼ同世代に出てきてライバル競合他者で
たたまオムの方が先に事件を起こして
捕まっただけていう感じ競技はオムの方が
幻覚って感じですねどっちかっていうと
その開立とかその仏教の式体とかそういう
のをきちんとやりなさいという感じで航空
の科学はどっちかってとお金メイン
とにかく金金あの金金っていう感じなんで
だから金が入れば別にんでもいいっていう
感じなんで競技的には結構緩かったかなっ
ていう違いはそこかなと思い
ますイ人生というのはどれほど幸福感を
味わったかによって決まるやろだから幸福
のなり方をまず身につけよそういうこと
言っとったんですよ幸福とはこうだから
こうすれば幸福になるさっきのあるやんね
価値を上げれゃええんや
からそう言うと竜自身は幸福だったのか
って考えると僕は幸福ではなかっただろう
なと思って最後のね死に方とかひどいもん
ですよ地分けた家族前菜子供たち5人と
全員と縁が切れた状態で死んだのでま授業
もどんどんうまくいかなくなってえ政党
やったけど潰してま映画もうまくいかなく
なって海外展開もうまくいかなくて信者
さんも増えなくて家族全員と縁が切れて
寂しくコロナで自宅で死んでいたって
考えると彼の最後は幸福だったのかなって
考えといや全然広告じゃなかっただろうな
て思うでだリをご露していただいた方が
良かったんじゃないか
もし大川竜宝さんがトヨットスクールに
入ってたらどうなってたと思いますか
いやいやもうソック逃げ出すと思いますね
りほは人間関係がとにかく苦手だったん
ですよねだから友達も全然いなくてで彼女
もずっとできなくて33歳まで童貞あ
つまり僕ができるまでですねあの僕を作っ
てようやく童貞卒業したというまそういう
ま悲しい男だったんですけども会社でも
人間関係が全然うまくいかなくて東大法学
部出て勝者入ったんだけどやっぱ対人関係
がダメだったからなるべく人と接触がない
部署に移されてそこで年間って感じだった
んですけどだからUFが入ったら集団生活
が向いてないので相当いじめられると思う
ですよね初日でいじめられてそれで
逃げ帰ると思いますねおそらくそんな根性
もないのでどうですかね期待直せますかね
彼は現実的になるんですよね合宿生活やっ
てねヨットていうのは精神を強くするため
にやっとるわけだから現実的になれば能力
をもっといかす方法を身につけたかもしれ
んねああっ現実的になるてのは大事ですね
や想の世界でねその霊が降りてきたとかね
そういうのに頼るんじゃなくてね一応東大
法学部出てるんだからちゃんとそういう
ペーパーテストはねある程度でき
るっていうのがあるんだからねそこ長所と
して現実を見据えた人生設計をしてれば僕
もこんな風にならなかったの
に本当にもう死んでから行っても遅いけど
ねということでございますね
はいJA